if you're wondering why you're looking
at a video of a man in a tank top it's
out of a closet it's because this is
actually where i work and i run
acquisition.com which is a portfolio
company that says about 85 million a
year and i have nothing to sell you the
reason i make these videos is because a
lot of people are broke and i do not
want you to be one of them and so uh in
this video i have a live recording of
grant cardone and i having a good
conversation about
life wealth real estate investing uh
business and a lot of other topics i've
consumed plenty of content and so i try
to ask questions that were a little bit
more off the beaten path and candidly
just questions that i was interested in
knowing the answers to and so the last
video did with grant uh was like one of
the top videos on the channel and so
this should serve as a good sequel to
that with some lots of kind of pressing
questions uh and a couple of surprise
moments that i think you will enjoy and
so if you're new to the channel welcome
to mozy nation we appreciate you and
i'll see you guys in the video enjoy
what's going on everyone i've got a
special
treat for you guys today um as you guys
know i've i don't ever have anyone on my
channel um and uh partially maybe it's
i don't know why uh but i think today
you will be very grateful uh that that i
was able to get in touch with grant
cardone and he was uh gracious enough to
give us an hour of his time uh and i
have some really cool updates for him
because a lot of you guys know uh on the
last time we spoke i give you some
updates of the things that grant advised
me to do and so it'll be cool to get a
little time lapse between then and now
and then as a quick side note for
anybody who's new to the channel welcome
to mozy nation uh our whole goal here my
name is austral mostly i own
acquisition.com we do about 85 million a
year in revenue and i have nothing to
sell you
and uh
the whole point of this channel is
because there's a lot of broke people
and i don't want you to be one of them
all right and so that's why we get the
best people here and try and try and
bring the advice of billionaires and and
nine figure earners uh to you guys so
that we can uh all get better together
so uh grant cardone i was actually
curious have you crossed the billion
dollar status
well first let me just say first of all
alex man it's really good to be here
with you and and i saw i saw the uh
breakdown you did of the coaching
session
and it was so refreshing to see that
literally i i don't know how it found me
or you know uh
i ran across it somewhere either was it
tick tock or instagram
and i started watching i was like this
guy's talking about me man and then and
then uh to hear the success that you had
had to hear that you had duplicated put
it to work
that you listened
um
not just for what i was telling you but
like it was just really refreshing to me
because one of the hardest there's two
things that that i'm really i don't
think i'm good at doing and that it's
it's difficult for me to do and one of
them is interviewing other people like
you're doing with me
it's one of the hardest things that i do
in my life
um and then the second thing is coaching
i told i told annie there i said no more
coaching i never want to do another
coaching session it's so difficult for
me and then when i heard you bro like i
i don't think it's actually that hard
for me i think that i don't get enough
feedback from people so when i heard
your feedback i was like annie do more
coaching let's do more coaching
so
so uh just really appreciate it now
regarding the net worth thing thing i
just want to do a disclaimer on net
worth
uh guys it's really not that important
like net worth is
it becomes important when you're trying
to make acquisitions
it becomes important when people
in in the finance world when you when
you grab a brick when you put a brick on
your net worth
uh i i'm going to tell you i did not
know this but the world pays attention
i have been fortunate enough and i'm
humbled to say this very grateful that
i'm able to show
a net worth that that catches those
eyeballs between the company's values
the real estate our cash accounts my
other investments
um
you know my sister asked me the other
day hey people are talking about you on
online are you really a billionaire you
know
and did you really get it and i'm like
look whatever i tell you right now
i'm gonna tell you yes or i tell you no
like
no matter what i tell you sis you're
going to say it doesn't matter you're
just my brother you know so at the end
of the day
you're worth 800 million 900 million a
billion 300 million you can't spend that
worth as you know
uh but it does open doors up if you can
ever get to a number substantial enough
and unfortunately goldman sachs and
blackstone and jp morgan and morgan
stanley
if you don't have that
they ain't seeing you right i hate to
tell you guys this but
you might have some local office call
and say hey we want to help you i'm i i
work with goldman sachs that's not
really goldman sachs that's some guy
that
has a little little little boutique he
did summer internship at goldman uh when
he was in college and he's uh off shoot
right yeah when i when i went to speak
with goldman just for everybody in the
audience um
it was uh 10 million was the minimum
investable right and so you gotta you
gotta have already you've got to be a
player already yeah
and and and one other thing on this
network thing thing because i'm very
sensitive to it uh when i did undercover
billionaire uh in 2020 january 2020 yeah
they called and said hey man would you
do undercover billionaire i'm like yeah
dude i'll do it could you do it you
think you can turn 100 into a million no
doubt about it
for sure
i don't need the 90 days by the way and
they're like my god you're so confident
that you can do it i said i know i can i
said but the problem i have with the
show
is the name of it yeah
and they're like why is that a problem i
said because at that time in 2020 i was
i had not crossed the threshold
and i was like look i'm just not i don't
i don't have that on my network they're
like yeah it don't matter it's tv man i
said yeah but it matters to me
only person matters yeah yeah yeah i i
want you to know that i uh i saw you
correct uh multiple people in different
interviews on that statement i just want
to let you know that i appreciated the
just the transparency so for me it was
meaningful um and that you brought it up
again so quick recap for everybody um
when i spoke with grant i was at an
interesting point i think i had about 25
million in after tax
um
that i had that i'd earned at that that
point so that's after tax decided taking
about 40 million out for my businesses
up to that point um and i was like what
do you think i should do with this um
and then what do you think i should do
with business and so the first piece of
advice you said was handle your wealth
first because i have too much attention
put on that so we went to work uh kind
of taking down chunks
of the money that we had there to put in
two investments put into large real
estate buildings and i'm happy to say
we've done a great deal of that um the
second thing was to focus focus on a
bigger opportunity vehicle um and it's
kind of interesting because you can hear
someone say something over and over
again but i think and i wish i'd give
this to everybody in the channel is that
like i had the opportunity to talk to
grant he was looking at me in the eyes
and said bro i think you needed 10x
because i told him my goal was to get to
10 million a month
and uh and he said why not 100 million a
month and so i actually redesigned the
business model uh to surpass a hundred a
hundred million a month and i actually
think that this model will do about 10
billion um i know that sounds like a
crazy number but i can walk through it
later um
the the third piece uh that you said was
recreate the conditions your success so
uh for us it was basically having the
immediate cash flow allocation uh being
a recurring piece of how our wealth
structure worked uh because it's the
vacuum of cash so that you have to suck
more in and up to that point i just
continued to stack cash and i had to get
better at the allocation on a regular
cadence um and the one fun thing that i
thought i would love to hit off with
this because i'll be honest with you
it's very top of mind for me is that uh
we have minority investments in in
three companies uh and then we have oh
sorry four companies i sold majority on
one of them and i have two companies
that i still own majority in that are in
the fitness space because that was the
niche that i came up in so i have a
supplement company and i have a gym
company gym licensing company
we have we put them to market um
basically after you and i spoke uh they
were on the market um we started
diligence uh 90 days ago so we accepted
an loi
this morning they came back and offered
me 45 million
um 30 million in cash
33 i would roll in the deal so that i
could participate in the upside
my question for you was
what i would like to do next is continue
to add to my portfolio and then take
acquisition.com which is my parent
company public in about five years so i
think we have to 250 top line 100
million bottom line and then go public
and so
i could take that cash after bonus
banker fees and whatever it's 22 million
i can add that and right now we have
about 35 million so i'd have 47 i'm
sorry 57 uh that would be my kind of
liquid
net worth and i'd still have a third of
those companies
i'm just curious what your input is
because you had said i really think you
should go after a bigger game and that's
what the acquisition.com brand is but i
spent the last year getting out of it so
i'm just curious
yeah so look uh i mean rich people sell
stuff and wealthy people never sell
anything
interesting sometimes sometimes wealth
is about the next level right like it's
about what wealth isn't always money as
you know for your audience it's like
what's my purpose
and a lot of people confuse this they're
like they do the purpose thing before
the money i would put the money first
then worry about the purpose uh 100
because you can't think about purpose
when you're operating from such a place
of scarcity if you can't pay your rent
you're not sure where your food's coming
from yeah might as well as hierarchy of
needs you're not going to get that level
right it's completely backwards it's
completely backwards it's very very
selfish by the way for people like i'm
doing purpose i'm saving the world first
man
nobody's even going to believe you
because the way you're rolling up
they they can tell that you're hungry i
i see bones on your body right like i i
see the terror in your face you can't
really create when you're worried about
feeding yourself and your family and
your employees you know when you got the
tax man when you're running games and
you're like okay i can't pay my taxes
right now because i need this cash to
get inventory like when you're playing
out
you just
it's not a good look
now if you have if you know how to get
resources like elon does
like elon doesn't need money he's got
access resources he knows how to grab
money mother teresa didn't need money
everybody everybody wants to use mother
teresa well she didn't need money she
had purpose mother teresa was so hooked
in
to a network of money she didn't need to
worry about money so number one you got
the wealth you got your financial thing
handled now it's like what do i want
that net to do
so you mentioned being exhausted i mean
it depends on how exhausted you are
no longer anymore so right now we that
was we spent the last year which is what
we made available yeah because because
kovit hits you you couldn't see a way
out of the deal you're like dude this is
getting exhausting i was telling people
doing co-vid they should be buying
businesses from exhausted people they
should have and if they have real estate
from exhausted people yeah q41 because
should come and made the offer i would
totally because because the burnout
burnout doesn't come from working too
hard burnout comes because i can't see
an end in sight
yeah like like okay i don't mind being
punished for some period of time yeah
it's when i don't know how long it's
going to go on that i'm like [ __ ] i
can't handle it anymore yeah but if you
told me it's only going to be another
six seconds i can hold my breath
so so um
so without knowing the opportunity and
exactly what you want to do alex i don't
know the right thing to do i know i've
regretted selling most the things that i
have really this is helpful for me
can i share one observation that i've
had because i've talked to i've talked
to a lot of advisors and just mentors
people who've done better than me and
the one commonality that i think you
might find interesting is those people
who have a lower net worth make less
money than me almost universally said
sell it that that's exactly right and
that's that's why i say rich people sell
stuff
and wealthy people
they don't sell yeah they just glob they
just
unless you know the party's over right
now a lot of wealthy people what they'll
do is they'll sell
they'll choke the next guy out
i know this sounds brutal
and then come back and buy the same
product the same business for pennies on
the dollar i know i know a guy's done
he's bought his business back three
times
wild
so a lot of these big companies what's
going on right now the whales there's
there's
the these whale companies need cash flow
and that's why this group came back to
you they can't find cash flow anywhere
i mean we're in a time that we have
never ever had on in on this planet ever
uh every day i'm looking at two emails
right now about properties i have where
people like hey i'm in savannah i saw
your deal we're willing to make you an
offer i'm from new york okay well
okay make me an offer
well i need to see your i need to see
your underwriting on your deal no dude
make me an offer like just
because i'm not i'm not a seller right
and by the way if i sell you
at the closing table
you're going to look in the mirror and
you're not going to find a head on your
shoulders because i'm taking your head
off
and and so the only because i i need
assets that cash flow yeah
and so if somebody's going to pay for
that then right now right now like no
other time in my lifetime people need to
pay a massive premium understood
i would i want to honor and respect your
time um so i can i would hit because uh
there's there's some things that i think
the audience would definitely love to
hear about so just as a uh so i have
written some some questions down that i
hadn't that i was curious about that i
hadn't heard from some of your past
interviews
so
you've been doing real estate since uh
you for since 25
i was uh my first real estate deal was
28 28. and i remembered a different
podcast you said at age 51 you had a net
worth of 6 million that then dropped to
1 million in the 08 you know crash was
that correct
so my my net worth at that time without
my house was uh about six million
dollars probably uh who know i mean i
was so terrified i had lawsuits i had
all kind of liabilities hitting me so i
could have been negative actually back
then but um it was
1 million felt like 6 million felt like
1 million 1 million was nothing so it
was all it was all like okay we're going
to zero here yeah and then then i had i
had at that time i had 14 million
dollars where the equity stuck in a
house
oh
and that equity
in one house
oh wow and so but you couldn't sell
houses then nobody wanted to buy a house
right but i had this primo freaking
trophy house
um and
uh
by the way your net worth is never ever
by sec definitions is never a
consideration of your net worth
so the i took i took when i discovered
that i'm like what the hell am i
thinking about i got all this money
trapped in a house man
so i sold the house got 14 million sold
it to a wealthy
wealthy family my neighbor
picked up 14 million took the entire 14
million and bought a thousand unit real
estate portfolio in florida i was in
california at the time
it's a good deal and
and decided to move east
oh way
that 14 million
uh that 14 million dollar investment in
that thousand units today's worth 314
million dollars
this this is perfect um because at least
to the next question and that house by
the way the guy in beverly hills says
man you sold that house too too soon
it's worth like 30 million now i said uh
yeah
so what
i said do you know what i did with the
money doesn't matter man you left a lot
of money on the table i'm like bro the
14 million
like
bought me a thousand units the cash flow
every month when i bought this deal the
the the rents were like 800 a month
today they're 1500 a month jeez
uh it the portfolio i could i could sell
it this sunday for 300 million
and uh 10 years from now it'll probably
be worth 400 million like it's never
going to stop taking care of me and my
family so that's a business right that's
a business that i didn't have to put
attention on
so that was actually one of the
i'm jumping but we'll just rock
the
the when you bought the portfolio
did you already have a manager in place
or did that portfolio already have all
that you know infrastructure in place
and you switched ownership
so
this is i was on a call yesterday with
robert kiyosaki and robert's like why do
you keep telling people to buy big deals
i'm like
why do you keep telling people to do buy
little deals
this is my show respect me i said okay
i know it's your show
and because i you invited me to your
show so we all know it's your show
robert but the point is robert like
just because you think two units and
four units is the somehow the holy grail
two units and four units don't come with
managers you just finished telling me
that management is the hardest damn part
and you keep talking about management
being the hardest part literally telling
your audience not to buy real estate
because how can i manage real estate
when i'm [ __ ] i can't even manage my
own life i got kids i got a job and now
you want me to manage a two-unit deal
he's like well what do you do for
managers i said i buy 500 unit complexes
400 unit complexes
this deal behind me is 230 million one
deal
16 employees come with the deal
so when i buy that deal i have built-in
leasing agents all of them stay with me
i have mechanics on the property one of
the reasons i've
avoided uh nevada as a real estate place
to buy apartments
is because i have to compete with steve
wynn's hotel for mechanics
okay so what i want to do is i want to
buy big buildings 200 400 800 600 unit
big buildings big
and for your audience it's like i don't
have that much money to buy that yes you
do you need to find people that you can
partner with on big deals great
locations and quit settling for the
crumbs it goes back to your second thing
that i told you in in in when we met
focus on big opportunities
yeah and two units can only make so much
money if the rents go up 100 bucks
that's two times a hundred it's 200
bucks nobody's gonna change your your
life is not going to be changed over
200. you change the rents on that thing
by 200
times 456. yeah
uh then all of a sudden everything
changes for everybody
right and your cap rates on those are
great so that 200 increase goes very far
yeah
so what do you think because i think you
alluded to it but i just want to nail it
down for reviews listening um i think
i've heard you say that you have a
perfect picker or a very good picker
yeah i have the perfect picker perfect
picker so
would you well
i'm asking you to spell it out so
you had six million dollars in net worth
prior when you're 51 years old
and you know fast forward now that same
thing all of a sudden you start picking
differently yeah
well let me just say this okay
that really didn't have that that's not
exactly what happened i had the perfect
picker
even then but i was terrified to pick
like like if i go back and look at all
the real estate that i've looked at i
bought in 11 states i have never ever i
know this is all like people though you
gotta you gotta miss no actually i have
never missed
i've avoided bad deals i've never bought
new york i pulled out of california i
had 2 200 units in in tucson arizona for
three years sold everything right before
the collapse
i know when to buy and i know when to
sell and if you guys
for the average real estate investor one
they're only looking in their market
like if you're only looking at one
market you cannot have a perfect picker
yeah because there's going to be cycles
in real estate where you can't even buy
if you're in indianapolis there's
there's moments where you cannot buy
indianapolis and then there's other
moments where you're like you need to
buy it right
so
lake charles louisiana where i grew up
uh
my entire the first 30 years i lived
there it was a terrible place to invest
it was a refinery town then the casinos
came to town and all of a sudden that
place like you would have just killed it
in lake charles
um so when i say i have a perfect picker
uh a lot of some people out there also
have perfect pickers but they ignore the
picking
think about the deal that you knew was
going to be a good deal but you didn't
buy it right
so now here's the formula for the
perfect picker which is i know what you
want to get down to okay
um
one you got to have courage
okay because you're not going to pick or
buy anything
like if you don't have the courage to do
it the courage comes from confidence and
it comes from the ability to raise money
get debt
so in the beginning man because i didn't
have any positive experiences
i knew it here but not i didn't know it
here
so you could talk me out of a deal
bed bugs could talk me out of a deal a
leaky roof could talk me out of a deal
right uh a yelp review uh the tenants
are pissed off at the property guy dude
nobody nobody likes where they live like
nobody nobody
i got people complaining of this
property and i'm 99
and they're complaining because i'm
raising a rents
so um
the picker goes like this okay when i
drive on a property number one
i'm not going to that unless there's a
story around it
jobs
government's positive
uh i own the property they're not going
to let everybody not pay me
i can evict a tenant when they quit
paying or when they're abusive to the
property like i don't go places where i
can't evict people got it now i know
some of your audience is going to find
that to be you know like oh my god man
dude look i got 456 i got 12 000
families that i'm responsible for i take
care of those families there's going to
be 400 idiots
400 people using too many drugs drinking
too much alcohol playing music too loud
not putting their stuff up tearing up
the property i have to get them off to
protect the 12 000 people that don't
want that
100
and so i have to do that for the
property i need to do it for my
investors and i have to do it for my
debt for the bank
it's a fiduciary thing to do so one i
got to have a story around the property
for me to go now once i go there the
second thing that has to happen is i
need to get this little vibration
this little like oh my god okay i need
this oh my god this is great that has to
happen to me it can't be like
if there's any i don't do it
is there is is that a function of price
like you go in knowing that now no no i
don't know anything about price yet
interesting okay i know nothing about
price price is one of the least
important things to me
price will keep you guys from buying
stuff
this this old it's what kept kiyosaki
from buying stuff buy low and sell high
he can't buy anything today
like he's like man well you're paying
too much for stuff about four billion
dollars worth of [ __ ] bro you ain't
bought anything in the last four years
you've missed the greatest real estate
escalation in the history of the united
states because you think it was too high
yeah the place is full it cash flows
it's not too high
there is no bubble there's no bubble in
this stuff that i'm buying
okay so one one i got there's got to be
a story around the property second thing
is i got to be like whoa
now i'm going to make sense of the
numbers okay the third thing that has to
happen before the numbers is the debt
great deals will always attract debt
good debt
so i need at least three lenders that
want to give me a loan on that property
otherwise i'm leaving this thing alone
what kind how much leverage do you try
and shoot for for and just for everyone
in the audience that the uh the building
is referencing is like an a plus i mean
it looks like it's an a plus type trophy
building um
with those types of buildings are you
able to attract higher leverage than you
would with uh no i mean yeah yes and no
i mean higher leverage is not what i'm
looking for though i'm looking for the
better property like even if i have to
go lower leverage
so
uh in the beginning when i was first
starting out
you know i made the mistake of looking
at what i could afford to buy
that was a mistake
buying real estate is not like
going to whole foods with a 200 budget
right or a christmas uh christmas list
yeah buying real estate man you're gonna
own and i think a lot of people approach
real estate like
okay i have x dollars i can go i can
afford this you're gonna you're gonna
buy the crumbs you're gonna be you're
buying leftovers yeah okay if you study
the wealthiest real estate investors in
the united states the donald brands
uh he's he's the he's
worth 17 billion dollars okay he but he
owns all of orange county he basically
built orange county uh uh california if
you study the fred trump's donald's dad
how he built his portfolio samsel how he
built uh
people argue with me about this i'm like
guys why are you arguing with me i'm
just following [ __ ] guys that are
legends
the these guys have already mapped the
deal out and i'm following them if i
look at what blackstone's buying today
that's what they're buying they're not
buying duplexes
they might invest
money in a company that's collecting a
thousand duplexes
but they're not buying one duplex at a
time so it's not just being a trophy
okay this this could be this could have
been the property before this
and maybe it was 200 units that were
a 1500 a month rents i would have still
bought it even though it's not a shiny
shiny beautiful building
that was definitely something that i
misunderstood from yeah yeah
so look i got 12 000 apartments in this
in this thing they all look different
some of them are 1990 some of them are
1995 some of them are you know 1200
rents some of them are these freaking
three thousand dollar a month rents
so so
uh what am i looking for one there's got
to be a story jobs government supportive
uh i got business owners
whatever yeah dude
like like like 20 percent of this
building's got new york residents in it
they think my rents are low
yeah
okay the 80 that's from florida
complains about the rent and the people
from new york are like dude these rents
are going to be five thousand dollars
yeah
and they're grateful for them so i'm
looking for a story number two i'm
looking for uh some kind of feeling like
god damn because if it pulls me it's
gonna pull the next guy the third thing
i'm looking for is great debt it's got
to have great debt okay debt being cheap
cheap rates
uh lenders that want to give me money
these big deals when you do a big deal
the thing that people don't know about
big deals until you start doing them is
the banks are not going to let you get
in trouble
yeah they i don't need an analyst
okay i went to goldman sachs on this
deal
they had 12 people underwrite this
through
like they got an unlimited
their expenses are more than my income
yeah okay a really interesting
perspective that i was not aware of but
makes complete sense i mean they're the
ones who are taking on the risk by
giving the loan right they're they're my
partner like you guys that are out there
like you want to own 100 i have this
lady tell me that i want to own the
whole building nobody owns a whole
building baby
you know like you're not you're not ever
going to own the whole building
it's impossible nobody owns the whole
building so when i go to goldman goldman
unleashes 12 guys as analysts
today's rents tomorrow's rents coved
rents problems uh like like you know my
i'm one analyst i do everything on a
piece of paper
right i'm like i'm buying this deal guys
i put it under contract we agree to a
price i sent it to them they're like we
love this deal then i shop it to another
guy jp morgan says we want the [ __ ]
deal and then kkr says we want to give
you money i got three major institutions
these are trillion dollar companies
they're like yes yes and yes
and and and now i know i'm backed up
with with no analyst by the way i don't
have an analyst i do not pay anybody
over here
to do the analyzing i'm using
these trillion dollar companies
intelligence same way i buy real estate
like hey where's starbucks where's whole
foods where's trader joe's yeah where's
the chipotle okay
is there a five-star restaurant in the
neighborhood why because i know public
five-star restaurant i know if those
people are there starbucks did their due
diligence on traffic counts
whole foods did their due diligence i
don't need to do as much work i'm
basically drafting off of these super
uh public companies that have to report
to their their shareholders
now now now on the price
like
now i'm willing to pay a price
okay the the fourth thing that i'm
looking for is competition on the
purchase
i do not want to be the only guy on this
deal
and these are off-market deals that
you're finding or are you finding them
uh this was on market okay five blocks
away i bought an off-market deal at the
same time
so once once i put this into play i
wanted i wanted activity on this deal
okay the reason i want activity
is because i need to know what my exit
is and who my exit is going to be to
so so the two guys that lost this deal
this deal is 230 million dollars that's
what i paid for it
there was two other guys willing to pay
230 million dollars
okay those those are not uh
chiropractors
they're not plumbers
it's not some startup business
it's not some guy doing his first real
estate deal who's buying a quarter of a
billion dollars worth of real estate
people that are committed to real estate
these are massive funds yeah okay they
they gobbled this building up
all they're looking at is where can we
go eat something else they're never out
of money this is their game
and they eat real estate for a living
that's what they do so i buy this
the guy that came in second
gets my phone number and calls me hey
man
let's talk bruh
okay before that he didn't even know my
name now he knows my name he's like
anyway we could do something like what
this is the name if i gave you the name
of the company you'd be like i hear
about them every day
um hey is there you know could we could
we pay you 10 million to go away
i'm like well you could
but i'm not going to take it
i'm in the same situation you're in
right now
he says well if you won't sell it
uh
what about what about partnering with us
okay goldman gives you the debt
we'll put up the equity you need 70
million in cash we'll do the entire
we'll do 60 million you keep in 10. i
said nah bro i'm not going to do that
he's like well why not
he's like that's a good deal i said nah
i'm going to go to instagram and
facebook
they're going to give me the 60 million
why would you do that grant well because
they're nicer people frankly
yeah okay fred on facebook is nicer than
you are you're you're not nice you have
a legal team that that you know it's an
entire
you know uh 50 000 square feet in new
york city you're just not nice and by
the way you guys are so rich
already
i am in a position to give this to the
everyday person so that me and alex
can be on this deal
and alex so when me and you close the
deal together me you and 5 000 of my
friends on instagram
this guy
the company with the rock you know the
company that you know
they're still buyers
five years from now when we go to sell
it for 400 million yeah
so if i feed him today i can't feed him
tomorrow
you can't feed somebody that's been fed
so i starve
the big the big wealthy group i use my
audience to raise the money
and then and then we'll go feed this
this uh
blue rock
blue pebble right
we'll feed blue pebble you know in the
year 2027.
no i can dig that so let me ask you two
questions that are related to that
so with regards to what you said earlier
about the wealthy never sell and this is
one of the conclusions that i've made
because i wrote this i tried to document
the decision making process from day one
we when we went on the markets i wanted
to see how my thoughts would change
throughout that so i could do it again
better next time
um
and the conclusion that i had was the
only reason to sell is to think that
the only reason to sell is to think the
party's over because if you're trying to
buy time you can solve that by learning
the skill of you know delegating and
hiring talent and incentivizing people
if if you know what i mean like it was
the only reason that i would think is if
you don't think that this thing's going
to be around
in the future so
or you're done you're done with the game
maybe you're done with the game do you
think you'll ever be done with the game
i mean that because this is not me but i
know guys that are done with the game
right they're just done with the game
they're like i just went out of the game
you know you when you were going through
covid there was a moment where you're
like i'm done
yeah if they'd got you then you'd have
tapped out
i know
it's unfortunate because now i feel bad
but like i feel like i learned from the
experience and very grateful so so the
other the other time though is when i
need money man i might need money right
so like like i sold those 2 200 units in
tucson
um i did the right thing i regret it now
but i did the right thing at the time
got it because i don't know that i had
the stomach
to weather
2200 units
through 2008 9 and 10.
uh now looking back 20 years later dude
i shouldn't have sold any of that [ __ ] i
should not have sold it bro it would
have got me through 2008 nine and ten it
would be worth double or triple what it
was then
um it would have paid me now for 20
years i would have earned 10 percent of
my money
uh
i would have gotten my down payment back
in cash flow or cash flow appreciation
no cash flow cap the cash flow that
thing was cash flowing at 10 when i
bought it it's probably doing today who
knows i mean i wouldn't even i had to
refinance the property twice right i'd
have all my money out i'd have
i think i paid 50 million for that stuff
i probably have i would have pulled 50
million out
have new loans on everything
um okay good
and uh
you know i'd be in heaven over there and
but but whatever dude i i didn't know
what i didn't know yeah i needed the
dough
and i used it to to make another move
one of the things that i think i would
want to highlight for for for the
business owners and one that they're
listening is
this process that i just went through
it taught me about capital markets and
so now i feel like a much deeper
understanding of capital markets having
gone through finished diligence passed
with flying colors they improved the
offer before i even asked for it because
because our numbers are our numbers and
our you know we audit our financials
every quarter like they're audit ready
and so
one of the things that he shared uh
earlier and he just alluded to again um
is that
loans are not income
and so
there are if you think about what's
going to happen if i were to sell this
business right or or versus keeping it
either way the bank's going to take down
70 of whatever the deal is whether it's
somebody else gonna buy it from me or i
just keep it because they're willing to
give that debt independent and so grant
was saying earlier about this building
about if we wanted to keep this and just
continue to sam zelda's you know for
lack of voter turbo um you just keep the
same one you buy it you hold it forever
and then every so often you just take
money out of it because the bank will
just give you more for it and all of
that's become income tax-free
it might am i
uh
100
see
this is so weird for people to listen to
because they're like what what do you
mean man like guys what you want is you
want
you want debt you don't want income
and the fact that you don't understand
this doesn't make us wrong
it just means you it just means you were
miseducated because we're all trained to
go to school get a job and earn income
but actually income's not what you want
now in the beginning you need
income
so i need like i need income in order to
buy stuff
but what people shouldn't do is they
shouldn't buy stuff with income they
should invest all income yeah so like
when when i get an extra thousand bucks
what i do is i take the thousand bucks
yeah
okay
and
i'm not gonna go spend any of the
thousand
like i'm gonna eat nuts
i'm gonna eat nuts i'm gonna eat
whatever you're eating right now i'm
just gonna eat that i'm a scarf if i
earn a somebody gives me a thousand
bucks i'm gonna take the thousand i'm
gonna put in that piece of that building
right there yeah and i'm gonna make the
i'm gonna get rid of the thousand
dollars and i'm just gonna wait for the
thousand to grow up
because i know 10 years from now
this is worth nothing and that
building's worth something
i don't know if it went up or not
but if i got a good picker i know for
sure it went up
and if i have a perfect picker and then
it went up probably three times
now now this is garbage so i go out and
get some more garbage i take take it i
collect the trash and then i get rid of
the trash and i keep duplicating this
until this thing
starts to send me money back okay and in
the beginning it's going to send me a
hundred dollars back even though i put
10 000 in
this is what this is how i change the
quality of my life
off passive income
not off of earned income earned income
goes into buildings
real assets or into my business
okay back into my business advertising
marketing self-improvement uh
you know fixing my building up whatever
into my properties buying more real
estate buying equipment if i'm a farmer
i'm going to buy a tractor yeah
i don't want i don't want money
i don't really want to make any money
then i want the crops to produce this is
a crop basically this is today's 21st
century's farmer's crop
and this pays me sends me back 10
my kids get 16 a month that's what they
can spend yeah
okay until that becomes 32 they can't
spend more than 16. this is how they're
learning about money all their money all
their earnings all their allowance
everything goes into real estate real
estate kicks in some money now they can
go to target and you know and waste it
all
i love that so they want to go to chanel
they want to go to chanel they need to
they need more they level real estate
they're going to have to buy some more
real estate because i'm not buying your
chanel
yeah let me ask you a quick question on
because you have what's the number of
businesses you currently own
okay well we got cardone capital that's
you know that's the big mac daddy now 4
billion we got cardone enterprises which
is an umbrella company for
cardone ventures
10x incubator
10x uh media which is a new company 10x
health systems
the 10x growth conference cardone
university
what am i missing grant cardone
foundation which is a complete
philanthropic to educate kids
that don't have dads
and mentor kids
i'm missing something in here 10x uh 10x
stages
um
my wife's got a company now underneath
that so i don't know what it is but
we had a t we had one company fail
through covid we killed it
so you'll hear me talk about eight seven
eleven like we added a bunch of stuff
this year
um
do you consider those active this is
where i was going with this is it when
you have once you once you've released
like cardone training systems right
that's it's one of your oldest
businesses
yeah
would you consider that at this point a
business that really just sits on the
balance sheet as an asset that produces
cash flow passively to you or do you
still consider it active no i would
still consider that active income it's
treated as active income
okay
i was i was very curious about your take
on yeah there's people working in it
there's people working in it now let's
say that i let's say that i got a
royalty from that let's say i sold that
and now
i got a royalty like i own a company
called the cardone group that i didn't
mention it's an automotive company they
paid me 20 grand a month to use my name
it's been there 20 years i get 39 of the
the net revenue completely passive
i'm never there i never do anything for
the company it's a royalty kind of
situation
um
you know i'm not there until until
something goes wrong and then i gotta be
there
understood and so you still have okay i
i i get where you're coming from so the
fact that because in the building that
you just talked about earlier there's 16
employees there so there's like there
are employees but you but that in your
mind is different than well they're
under that llc they're under that
property that's going to be the los alas
walk it's going to be 10x los olas walk
fort lauderdale and it'll be an llc and
that llc and that business will support
those employees
there i want to make sure that we hit uh
the fun stuff um fun and fun uh so just
a quick disclaimer from from my legal
people um
you know true true the slogan on my
channel i have nothing to sell you uh so
this is not financial advice i'm not
endorsing this fund or any other funds
or investments i've ever mentioned on my
channel um i'm personally not invested
in the fund um and grant and alex i'm
reading this are professional uh
marketers and investors they look at
data and make decisions like grown-ups
and you should too so just want to say
that beforehand um so right off the top
i think people don't even know what the
word means so what is a fund
uh fund
uh is a uh
is a structure
so that alex can and i are me and my
brother
um
it could be a small tiny fund it could
be three people it could be 35 people it
could be 3 500 people
uh typically in the past it was
it was um
before 2012 it was really just a wall
street term
okay and a guy like me couldn't do a
fund it was just the blackstones and the
goldmans and the jps they had funds
2012 barack obama uh signed a thing
called the jobs act that allowed a guy
like me to set up a fund so that
you and i
i did not know you huh i did not know
that yeah yeah 2000 so i could actually
go to my friends and say hey guys you
want to invest with me in 2016 that that
law was
changed to actually allow
not just accredited
investors that make 200 grand a year or
more but also those that make
199
999.99
and below
they could also invest
and so we just opened up this deal by
the way uh to
non-accredited and accredited
this has never been done before
and uh i'm not a financial advisor i'm a
professional real estate investor yep
and i bought 40 plus pieces of real
estate 4 billion worth of real estate i
mean i know what i'm doing when it comes
to real estate
so so so i buy this deal with my money
i get a loan under my name and not my
net worth the loan on this will be 170
million dollars
so most of the people investing with me
probably can't get that loan you put 60
in because there's 230 right so
i put 69 million in and then finance the
rest uh on a five-year loan
oh wow that's a short moment
yeah i signed on the loan i'm
responsible for the debt and then i tell
my my friends and followers and my
family and the employees hey guys you
can put a thousand bucks in this deal
you can put ten thousand bucks in this
deal you could put two million dollars i
got buddies of mine that are going gonna
put 10 million dollars in this deal
the guy that puts in 10 million gets
exactly the same terms as the guy that
puts in a thousand bucks
and and the reason i'm doing this is
because one has never been done before
the little guy has never got a shot at
these deals
and i come from very humble beginnings
i'll never forget where i came from
and i want to make i want to make a
difference i i think this is why so many
people
in the middle class have been are being
held back
is because we we as a class of people
actually never get a shot to invest in
the best stuff
we don't know how don't have the time
it's too complicated it's very big you
know they're big deals they require a
lot of money and now
um
alex you could become my partner in that
deal for just a thousand bucks
and then you just got to sit and wait
for me to do the right thing with it
you're a passive investor
and it could be five years it could be
10 years
who knows maybe the whole building just
disappears suddenly into the into ashes
we got insurance for that by the way
which is good
could be
sleep a little better so on so question
um for the fund
do are each of the buildings uh do they
have separate or different terms or is
every building that you buy the same
terms pretty much the same terms and
everything so the only thing different
on this deal is if you're accredited and
you put in 500 grand you get a check
every month
distribution every month
if you're not accredited and you do a
thousand bucks you're going to get a
check every quarter just because the
check size is going to be so much
smaller got it the terms of the deal are
identical
so for uh uh we can just walk through
this if that is that okay with you
yeah i got a 3 p.m with cnbc we just got
it
well then um
i'm just going to read the rest of these
uh
all right we're gonna ask you the last
question that i was gonna ask you okay
so we said earlier that uh
some guys want to get out of the game
at some point
if you were to get out of the game
i don't see you as i could be wrong but
i don't see you as the type person to
not do something or play
what game will you play
yeah good question so no no number one
is uh um i am gonna get out of the game
my in
cause i'm tired of playing a little
really
okay okay so so i'm at four billion
dollars worth of real estate i'm going
to 50 billion i'm going to get 50
billion dollars with this stuff right
here
and i'm going to become one of the
largest apartment owners in the country
that's the new game the game that i was
in i'm quitting the game i was in the
game that i was in was a game for me it
was just for me and my family
now i'm going to be in the game i'm
going to build a bank
i'm building a bank i'm telling
everybody right now what i'm doing
uh this is going to become everybody's
bank
right now right now your audience
doesn't know it right now but you guys
invest in my deal now you just don't
know you invest in my deal
and the way the game works now is this
you guys give your money to wells fargo
and bank of america and citibank
yeah
and then they call they call as soon as
you drop the money off they call goldman
sachs
and goldman's like
yeah we can put that money out on the
streets
and they call me and then they they they
take your thousand dollars and lend it
out nine times to guys like me
so the average american person been
investing in my business
for years without any of the upside
[Music]
none of the appreciation none of the tax
write-offs none of the cash flow none of
the lift none of the leverage none of
the benefits
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to bypass the system
uh the only people that cannot invest
with me are people that want to use a
middleman can't use the middleman
schwab can't call me fidelity can't call
me wells fargo can't call me
it's straight me and alex do a deal
together and that's it got it so there's
no llc's i can invest yeah so well you
could you you could as an individual llc
invest with me but that'd be a choice
and it's not necessary
i want to be respectful of your time i
know you said you have cnbc so i just
want to say thank you so much brent um
i'd rather i appreciate you man
appreciate who you are appreciate what
you're doing and i appreciate that that
you're you're a great example of
somebody that's learning the game
sharing it with people
and and super well done on all your
successes
[Music]